[Music]
in making Asians proud news jumbo for I
don't know when we're proud enough
though like it's always like not good
enough they never make me proud to be
honest really what he's being their
agent that oh yeah I play my role
it's never good enough submitted by ball
in one of the best basketball dunkers in
the world is an Asian man oh I saw this
guy basketball dunkers just a trampoline
[ __ ] where they're doing like a lot of
trick dunk stuff what I'm come treat Wow
we're living in a new age I only know
Asians that are Sherman's that's the
only Sherman I've ever known we know
Asian Sherman Sherman Merman from Bad
Santa a little [ __ ] fat kid oh yeah
or maybe it's Thurman Merman I think
it's Thurman having a non-asian Sherman
right yeah yeah so I'm gonna show you
guys a video of his dump pretty dope
that's mind blowing
oh wow food seven feet tall and then
I've seen bikes before yeah I've seen
those before he's 6 1 oh dude he's gonna
[ __ ] I mean he's good but he's not I've
seen you suck can you know I want to see
what make those passive 360 what you
guys doing that right now all of these
things if it's the NBA dunk contest
they're all like seven or eight like
seven or eight that might have been an
eye on the not gonna make it but it
keeps going yeah yeah it's like he's
barely on the edge
wait why did that one get that reaction
this is more people there alone it's
like wow you've never seen you dunk
before like he's been dunking me crazy
I'm not proud cause it's not me
so Khalif which is one of our friends
hmm he can do all of those but believe
is half black yes
he's also happy the meze but the
Vietnamese part doesn't slow him down
true he's the average average dunker and
I think it's just he is getting
attention because he's Asian so I'm
proud that he's Asian is dope that
Asians are getting to other things
besides trying to be like an engineer
but is an average dunker dude 360 eggs
already remarkable yes all of them are
average ducks between the legs those are
all average ones jumping over someone
that's under six feet tall that's
average dunks that's you're saying if
that was a black dude you and be
impressed yes like that would be below
average yeah what's a spectacular dunk
so a spectacular dunk these days if you
watch the NBA looks like three four
people standing and you jump all over
them they're going up as their body is
like spinning this way they thunk the
other way it's like some crazy [ __ ] I
just don't understand the Asian
community cuz ya'll roof on each other
so [ __ ] alright like if it was a
Mexican person me and TIFF would be like
oh [ __ ] they were Cuban I don't give up
for Latino you know that was a white guy
I be like Oh David did a movie called
white man can't job that's true that's
really breaking stereotypes right there
I'm six more and I've never been able to
dump
you knew your donkey we wouldn't give a
[ __ ] that it's average or whatever I'm
like [ __ ] yeah you're shedding some
light on my pimple oh [ __ ] yeah let's do
it let's I don't give a [ __ ] if it's
been done a million times I might let
recognize this we're right here -
[ __ ] but you guys are like oh
that should happen we just got high
standards it's unbelievable standards
but what Geo saying is they also do all
the Asian pride stuff I like confusing
so it's confusing you know what you know
why it's confusing cuz we're not a
monolith that's why I see we don't think
one way you go to the Venice Beach
basketball courts yeah all day everybody
that's there all they do they unify like
we like [ __ ] yeah my Asian people but
this is now this is what the media
thinks of us we know all of y'all exist
this will just open up the gates to all
y'all now the ones that aren't average
come on through this guy's opening up
the gates for all of us let's do it I'm
just mad cause it's not me I get that I
wanna be number one I've never seen you
with the basketball no that's what I'm
saying cuz I'm like I'm just jealous
that he put in the work and I'm gonna
blame him cuz he's tall okay I respect
Sherman he's been he started dunking
since he was 15 he's now 24 he's six
foot one Toronto so he actually says
something similar to a bar was saying so
it's not good enough I bet you're gonna
say he was he said something about
partner oh no [ __ ] defend him I know I
said all what I said well what was up he
was saying that like in the beginning
when he heard like oh you know he's the
best dunker that's like the Asian guy
the Asian best Asian dunker or whatever
so he was like oh that was cool but then
now I'm starting to feel like that's
just that's limiting because it's like
he wants to be beyond what is the the
high standard yeah he wants to be
trend-setting which is like what Bart is
talking about is like it's like it kind
of feels like a consolation prize where
it's like oh you're pretty good for an
Asian dude so it's kind of like oh good
for you you know you can actually dunk
but then the bar set so low because he's
agent but I think what the people are
celebrating is that he's breaking a
stereo - yeah
bingo is this ourselves right when you
got me he broke the stereotype
he can't duck though no I can't not
super tall yeah well y'all wasn't like
incredibly athletic guys but not like
this is that's pretty intense
athleticism Jeremy Jeremy definitely
brought some syrup yeah yeah cuz he was
crossing people up you know what I mean
like he's probably the first person that
I can think of those Asian that hooped
at all right level yeah yeah and he was
going for 30 30 30 like you know what I
mean like he he plays like an Americans
yes yeah
plays like a Chinese person yeah you're
a textbook yeah Epis glasses before it's
free throws yeah I see when I see a
white wide receiver in the NFL I'm like
I want to see one that's not on the
Patriots have a touchdown they still
dance my heart fills with pride one
thing I don't get is like all the
receivers after they're done making the
TAT touchdown
they have this insane choreographed
dance that I'm like how do they spit do
they spend all that time knowing all the
[ __ ] handshakes they do yeah they do
yeah just for the touchdown when I get a
touchdown I want to do it like this they
plan that [ __ ] practice like during
practice you get so hype about something
you do and you just start doing it and
then it's a practice thing and then you
just bring it on the field
I thought of sense cuz they're a block
they're just so good at dancing they're
just like you know what dance will of
course speaks to my black house in my
white house there's only two Asian dudes
yeah when her the computer crashed we
thought just me at him and looking at
each other we gotta fix this [ __ ] no one
else did what do you think is like man
don't stereotype me I what's wrong and
I'm not even good at computers and we
just knew it was gonna come down to me
or him I also love how we so in the NFL
you you see it touch not get scored and
then the team races over and they do
this team photo thing have you seen that
yeah yeah and then I
when they do that they take the team
photo but then they lose the game so
it's like they add this bow tie it all
up then they lost the [ __ ] game it's
like dude it's like remember that time
we [ __ ] lost so there's always people
photographing on the sidelines like the
NFL photographers all they face the
audience and like take a team photo like
that in the middle of the game yeah like
after they scored touchdown and if they
lose the game it's like dude I think the
funny thing about this is once you've
been exposed to a lot and you've met a
lot and learned a lot it won't surprise
you that like an Indian man is dunking
or at or a Native American man is
dunking it's like Oh at lettuce ISM just
happens when you're genetically like
that way you work hard for it right it's
like if you're tall you have all the
right things you know you work hard you
can get that done right but the thing is
you know a lot of us live in bubbles so
you have these ideas of like oh that
can't ever happen right which is the
stupider thing to think but then the
more you get exposed to you've seen it
you've seen a tall asian person or
whatever you're like oh that's nothing
I've seen that already but I think back
in a day I was under the impression that
we couldn't gain muscle because a lot of
Asian people were skiing right but then
we go to the gym and we see all these
like ex-con Asian dudes that are like
ripped and were like oh [ __ ] so it can
happen were they born that way but the
perception is just different because
they're you live in a [ __ ] bubble and
you think that Oh Asian guys can't get
muscle or they can't be athletic because
no one around you is yeah so that I
think that kind of stuff is kind of
important yeah which contest was he
winning when he was 17 years old he won
the Sprite Slam Dunk showdown in 2012
don't kiss the Sprite Slam Dunk showdown
Kofi come on have some standards man say
like fabulously
is it worthy of a kiss for like a
[ __ ] dope trophy what the [ __ ]
what's he gonna have access to this
white one is a dope trophy I don't know
but he wants to be the best of the world
like safer for some show it's a
competition for them he's not gonna be
able to kiss the NBA Finals true yeah
what is the career progression for like
someone who's like a dunk specialist
like is it the Globetrotter they're like
yeah yeah trip game kind of stuff like
they actually have the dunk TV show I
think this is the first year maybe first
or second year on tnt they had like a
dunk kings or something like yeah he was
actually on that in 2016
she was in the inaugural season the dunk
king it's a TNT reality show the dunk
cameras have been three four years that
means it didn't really pop off like I
thought it did we should do a
documentary about the Washington
Generals the guys who play the
Globetrotters definitely the
Globetrotters every time and they lose
every time they lost every [ __ ]
season they're like the guys that
couldn't get into the gold whoa I can't
guard you like before Bill Burton whole
basketball game exactly yes no charters
for the Washington Generals dare to get
trampled on yes like the bump is there
like basically the buffalo bills or the
Browns of the show it's just a show yeah
technically like shoot some points but
they're just there to whiff while the
guys reading it like they're a real team
and like how one day they'll win like in
the documentary phone will be pretty fun
okay there really like the rodeo clowns
they just yes oh I thought it was guys
that couldn't make it
no they probably couldn't make it
it's like if you're doing an audition
for me right now for the Washington
Generals I'm like okay I'm gonna dribble
around you got a look really confused
like ready go
they're like the putties for power
ranger yeah dumbass thought they really
got juked
No
really I haven't seen it since then okay
but you're watching the last week live
man these guys know what the generals
finally fire the [ __ ] coach press
conference with the Jarosz close leg
will you mama Globetrotters have some of
the best athletes in the world it's
really tough we're gonna get it fixed
they were that good that's why and I was
like how come they don't play in the NBA
that's great
[Music]